اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله
الذي بنعمته تتم الصالحات
والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه وسلم
حضور جميعا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اولا
تحيه واجبه لاهلنا
التحيه واجبه
لاهلنا في اقليم مدينه الازرق
تحيه
انتم اهل الله و تستحقونها جميعا
نحييكم
باسم القوات المسلحه انتم
ظللتم دوما
حاضر امين لهذه المؤسسه
مؤسسه السودان الاولى
شكرا لكم شكرا لما قدمتموه من كرم اصيل
ينمو عن اصاله
عن كل افرادنا المتواجدين في هذا المكان
وفي كل مكان اخر من السودان
تحيه لي كل قواتنا المسلحه وقواتنا
النظاميه
للقائمين على امر هذا المهرجان تحيه خاصه
للفرق الفائزه
وللمتفوقين
القادمه 58
نكون قد استكملنا بناء ونهضه قوات المسلحه
او على الاقل وضعنا طريق وضعنا اقدامنا في
الطريق الصحيح لكم
التقدير جميعكم اولا نحن في هذا المقام
يجب ان نذكر بان اقامه المهرجان في هذا
المكان كان يواجهه تحدي تحدي كبير
[موسيقى]
الممالك
المملكه السمان مملكه
كلها المنطقه قديمه مالك قديمه ظلت ترعى
السودان وظلت هي حاضنه لكل شعب السودان
نحنا كلنا كسودانين حزينه كثيرا لما جرى
من احداث وحزين ما كثيرا للتناحر والتباغض
الذي دب بين ابناء الوطن الواحد وبين
ابناء المنطقه الواحده نحنا هذه الفعاليه
فعاليه عسكريه عسكريه لكن
قلنا يجب ان تشتمل على داعمي القوات
المسلحه من ابناء الازرق كلهم جميعا هم
داعمين وهم مؤسسين للقوات المسلحه لذلك
راينا انه صاحب معنا ما ضل يؤرق
السودانيين وما ضل يشغلهم في الفتره
السابقه من الاحترام والصراع القبلي الذي
نحسب انه كان سحابه عابره يجب ان تضل
صحابه عاذره ويجب ان نصمم على انها سحابه
عابره يجب ان لا نسمح لهذه الاحداث بان
تتكرر الناظر للخريطه الديموغرافيه في هذه
المنطقه يرى كل السودان موجود هنا كله هذا
الكلام ده لاهلنا كلهم
من كل القبائل الموجوده
كلهم كلهم
[موسيقى]
البلد دي بلد السودان السودان ده كلنا
احنا
عايشين قديمه كانت مستوعب الناس كلهم
والناس كلهم كانوا عايشين فيها نحن نحزن
لانه في زمن او في القرن ال 21 وال 22
تطلع الامور او الكلام اللي احنا تجاوزناه
والعالم تجاوز وشعب السوداني تجاوزوا مئات
السنين نحن يجب ان نسموا
ونستسلم مستقبل ابناءنا ومستقبل شبابنا
لاننا هذا البلد هذا السودان يسعنا جميعا
نحن كلنا نحترم الاعراف والتقاليد القبليه
القائم عليها السودان نعترف
ان هنالك اسس قبليه وتعالى
مخصصه للاداره هذه الحواكير نحن نقول الله
السعاده الحكومات لفرض السيطره على الناس
الموجودين كل ممكن نعشيها ما في زول ما لم
يحرق العادات واللوائح والنظم والمجتمعيه
بعد ذاك ممكن الناس يجيبوا يتكلموا معاهم
تكلموا معاهم بالقانون تكلموا معه
بالشيء مرعي برده نحنا بنفتكر انه هذه
العادات والتقاليد السامحه يجب انها تخرى
يجب ان لا ننشي نظم اداريه فوق النظام ده
كله عادات وتقاليد نحن كلنا حافظناها بقى
على السودان ده في السنين الطويله القديمه
او ثلاثه شهور
وصلنا في النهايه لكلمه سواء تجمع اهلنا
نرجو ان نحافظ على هذه الكلمه هيكون عندنا
لقاء اخر نستقبل فيه وهذا الامر نحن هنا
يجب ان نحيي في هذا المقام اخونا مالك
مالك عقال شكري كبير جدا
هذا الرجل